well we begin this newshour with
breaking news
the german government says tests
conducted on russian opposition figure
alexey navalny
have revealed unequivocal proof that he
was poisoned last month with a chemical
nerve agent
the prominent kremlin critic fell ill
during a flight to moscow
he's in a serious but stable condition
at a hospital in berlin
where he was brought from siberia 10
days ago a german government spokesman
says toxicology tests on blood samples
show the chemical used is from the
novichok group of nerve
agents doctors who treated him in russia
say they found no
evidence of poisoning well in a moment
we'll cross to moscow for reaction from
there but first
our correspondent nadine barber joins us
live from london where he's been
following developments in germany
nadim i see that um the german foreign
minister is now
insisting on a russian investigation
that's right the the german government
has reacted very swiftly
and very toughly to this uh news from
the military laboratory in germany
heikemas the foreign minister
has said we condemn this attack in the
strongest possible terms
leaving no room for doubt that the
germans believe this was a deliberate
poisoning of alexei navalny
heikemas has summoned the russian
ambassador to germany for talks and he's
called for
those responsible to be found without
actually suggesting who
they might be but it's clear that the
germans are very very unhappy
about this and very clear about what
they think has happened
of course earlier in the day uh a
spokesperson for
chancellor angela merkel had said that
this military laboratory
in germany had found quote the doubtless
presence of a a poison
or rather an agent from the novichok
group um and of course that's come um
after tests um from mr navalny who has
been in an induced coma in the
charity uh hospital in berlin now for
some while
i imagine nadine in london this must all
be reviving memories of sergey skripal's
poisoning back in 2018
of course that's what people will think
of when they hear the word
novichok it's a soviet era nerve agent
and it was found to have been used
on sergey skripal a former russian
a former russian spy and his daughter in
south west england
two years ago now they were both ill
but in fact the um substance ended up
killing a member of the public
who happens to find a container
containing some of the leftover
uh agent uh just uh if you like on the
streets
uh and all along russia uh denied any
involvement in that even though the
british authorities actually
identified the two russian men who they
think
actually carried out the attack and it
caused a lot of
uh alarm almost panic particularly in
the city of salisbury
where the attack happened but because
for months the authorities couldn't tell
people
exactly what had happened and where the
substance had gone
so yeah it really is a worrying
situation the dean baba
in london for us thank you so much
nadine well let's now move over
to alexandre stroyanovich godfor to get
the view from moscow
alexandra this has all happened i know
just over the last hour or so but i see
we are already getting some pushback
from the kremlin
yes exactly whilst the german reaction
was fifth year reactions are
cautious and restrained in a way
so ministry of foreign affairs responded
by saying that russia is still waiting
for a german prosecutor general office
to respond to their request
and their request was to send all the
results of the analysis that
were done to navalny also to state for
instance what was the level of his
cholinesterase
in the plane so before he arrived into
germany and german clinic
wanting all these details um and
a member of a russian parliament he's
actually ahead of the russian
committee for foreign affairs in the
parliament he said that russia is very
willing to cooperate
but these statements coming from germany
have to be followed with some solid and
concrete
proof so the situation now is that from
the authorities the reaction is still
restrained but we heard before
that the russian doctors found no poison
they actually released navalny
with the diagnosis of metabolic disorder
disorder of
carbohydrates and that two labs in in
russia
didn't find anything suspicious and the
investigation
which is actually in a pre-investigative
state didn't found
any reason to think of any any foul play
on the other hand opposition is uh
saying in one voice
we knew it all the symptoms were there
and
a friend of navalny and his colleague
evangelist
tweeted that using novichok is actually
like signing the crime uh saying that it
can only be used by
certain state organizations namely by
for instance military intelligence or
the state security service so the
opposition
is pointing fingers and they're pointing
fingers at the authorities well i want
to ask you more about that alexander
because as nadine was saying
the novichok group of agents was what
was used on sergey skripal
back in 2018 and then it was linked to
the military intelligence agency the gru
so does that now make it
more difficult for the kremlin to
distance itself from this
well yes it does but if we go back to
the skripal case uh
even though scotland identified two
suspects
and journalists also identified them as
members of the military intelligence
russia denied it they said these are two
russian tourists they were completely
innocent they were sightseeing in
salisbury
we saw um in famous interview with this
two people
uh claiming they have nothing to do with
anything and this
is a sort of a pattern that we are
seeing that
when some other state accuses russia of
some
power play of poisoning their opponents
or double agents like in a case of
script
russia is saying it is not us or there
is no
evidence and you have to provide us with
solid proof
and what you are giving us is not solid
proof so
it wouldn't be surprising if we get such
an
answer now in this case alexander
strojanovic godfor there
for us in moscow thank you so much
alexandra